[Music]
what are you thinking about I do what I
do because of my dad he was a hero he'd
give his life from the pursuit of
knowledge control getting that over
[Music]
it's crazy out there there's fires
everywhere and plane crashes they're
calling it the search major we have some
highly classified information what can
you tell us about the Lima project its
objective was to search for advanced
extraterrestrial life the ship
disappeared approximately 16 years into
the mission and the commander was it was
my father Sir this might come as quite a
shock to you your father was
experimenting with a highly classified
material that could threaten our entire
solar system all life would be destroyed
we're counting on you
to find out what's happening out there I
worry about you I love you please begin
your psychological evaluation as best
you can please describe your current
mental and emotional state I am feeling
good ready to do my job to the best of
my abilities
I remain fully committed to the lawful
completion of the mission if necessary I
will destroy the project in its entirety
the earth was hopes in him
and now it's fake just on me
we have a job to do are you ready I'm
ready
[Music]
[Music]
you